so this is a this is a molecule of
morphine
I'll just take you around the molecule
so we have oxygen in red and the blue
one is nitrogen that's really important
and the black ones there are carbon so
the whole combination of those makes up
this quite interesting looking scaffold
you can see if you look down there it's
kind of t-shaped you've got a fairly
flat top and a fairly tall upright bit
here and that's really important for the
way it interacts morphine obviously is a
painkiller a so-called analgesic so
morphine and all the oak so called
opiate analgesics come from poppy seeds
and these poppy seeds produce the most
of these compounds when they come from
Afghanistan or Pakistan for some reason
the the growth of the poppies they're
producing much much more of these
compounds now there's a problem with
that possibly because obviously over the
years those countries have had all sorts
of political instability there can be
issues with getting the the compound out
of there and so synthetic chemists have
tried to develop syntheses of morphine
which wouldn't rely on those countries
to source that the wrong feedstock fuel
and it's a very complicated molecule as
you can see we can make it but it can't
be made cheaply enough for it to be
commercially viable so another problem
with morphine apart from how to source
the raw material is that the horrific
side effects it's got so it can give you
nausea depression it gives respiratory
depression slows your breathing down you
get tolerance to it so the more you have
it the more you need for it to give the
same effect and you get terrible
withdrawal symptoms as well but the key
thing it does have is it is a brilliant
analgesic or painkiller the real deep
pain like the your broken leg there is
nothing else which can ever approach it
for that and believe me medicinal
chemists have tried all sorts of things
they've tried making it
it's more complicated and that led to a
couple of interesting compounds which
actually fitted in the same key hole but
didn't produce any pain killing effect
at all so in the Second World War
obviously supply of of morphine and
other painkillers is a real problem and
actually the Germans came up with a much
simpler compound so if we look at this
compound here this is a called me
paradeen or pethidine as you'll know it
in the hospitals if we overlay those you
can see that it it fits pretty well so
it interacts this is in the same sort of
place here the nitrogen is in the same
sort of place it interacts with the same
receptor it's about a fifth is active
it's more thing it's also much quicker
to get in to the receptor do its
business and get out so these days this
is used in childbirth to help relieve
the pain and relax
the the mother-to-be now there are
various other opiates that you may have
heard of and it's amazing what one atom
can do really or what one one functional
group is we call it as chemists can do
so this is morphine so if we pop this
one on here that now is coding now
codeine is around a hundred times less
active than morphine in fact is so
relatively safe and inactive you can go
and buy it in a chemist is cocoa dermal
or other brand names so it's amazing
what that one little thing is done it's
completely tamed the Beast in many ways
encoding has far less of these terrible
withdrawal effects as well so if we take
that off and we put on a couple of these
groups so you can see that there's some
more oxygens coming in here these are
called acetate groups that now is called
heroin which I'm sure you'll have heard
of and Herron actually is more active
than the morphine very slightly more
active and it's also got
even worse withdrawal symptoms she's
seen Trainspotting you love ye love
noticed her not very pleasant it is as I
say more active than the morphine so
heroin is used in hospitals in in acute
cases of deep pain it's not called
heroin hospital so I guess that's a
slang name which is come around
it's called diamorphine because it's a
die acetate or acetal morphine and all
of these things work by stopping nervous
system messages getting to the brain the
pain messages so that so the messages
are still being sent from the broken
limb whatever but it's it's stopping
those messages getting to the brain
which is why they're so effective in
really deep pain yes yes I was playing
basketball I landed very badly also once
when I had a is and the teeth under my
teeth I have a tooth removed and my god
that was the worst pain I've had in many
many years